how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and lately we've been learning
a lot of new information about the
marvel
cinematic universe specifically things
that we could have never known about
before because they weren't released
on screen these are things happening in
the mcu but off screen that we never had
a chance to learn about until
now if you caught my video yesterday
about shuri possibly becoming the new
black panther and creating a new
heart-shaped herb then you heard me talk
about a new
marvel cinematic universe tie-in book
called the wakanda files
now basically what it means by a tie-in
book means that anything that has
happened in the book
has happened in the mcu we just didn't
see it but what it's doing is telling
us what's going on in the background in
places like wakanda while the events of
the avengers happened
and there are some pretty cool reveals
in this book and one of those things
that has been revealed
is how tony stark discovered spider-man
was
insanely impressed by him and the plans
that he had for him
this was never revealed until now and
i'll go over the whole entire thing but
real quick if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win an
imposter spider-man funko pop so when
spider-man was first introduced into the
marvel cinematic universe he was
introduced in captain america civil war
and we kind of got a backstory for him
but we didn't get his origin we didn't
see the radioactive spider
we essentially just saw some youtube
videos of spider-man protecting and
saving people
and according to the wakanda files
that's what tony saw at first too
and he decided to do some of his own
investigating
in the book tony stark writes this down
himself about peter parker he says
this kid in queens that's blowing up on
youtube is a bit more interesting than a
cat playing a harmonica
get this some teenager gets bit by a
spider and suddenly shows up some of the
best in the avengers squad
and i don't think these are special
effects this kid is catching an
in-motion vehicle traveling at 45 miles
per hour
that's like 3 000 pounds worth of
vehicle
how so right away tony is already super
impressed and really
amazed but one thing that's really
interesting here is that he mentions a
spider
something that we've never heard with
tom holland spider-man so although they
didn't show us the spider bite like they
have in pretty much almost every other
spider-man
that is still indeed how spider-man got
his powers they did not change that part
but tony stark goes on to do entry logs
about spider-man and he realizes that
he's created his own
webbing and he says he's created this
webbing from what
over-the-counter products he's buying in
a bodega if he created
all of this tech scrapping together
garbage think what he could do with the
playground we've built upstate
so this is where tony saw the entire
vision he saw spider-man joining the
avengers he saw spider-man going to
upstate new york to the avengers
facility and working on a new spider
suit because we all saw
the first spider suit that he had in
spider-man homecoming lordy
can you even see in these yes yes
but as it turns out tony stark actually
created the nanotech
iron spider suit as sort of a bargaining
method to get peter parker to join the
avengers
it was kind of like an incentive it was
kind of like hey if you join us you get
this really awesome suit
in his next log he says once he's got
the hang of the upgrades let's lend him
a hand
or four if we give him nanotech spider
legs that build out from his back
it can be a safeguard from falling a
defense mechanism we won't get carried
away like cross did with that
yellowjacket suit but
it could be a fun touch so two very
interesting things here
one is that the iron spider legs that
come out of the iron spider suit were
kind of a fail-safe for tony
now by this point in time he was kind of
protecting peter parker he was already
his mentor and he wanted to make sure
more than
anything that he didn't get hurt so the
legs were protection for peter parker if
he fell from a very far height which we
actually saw happen in avengers in game
and then we saw the instant kill mode
but another interesting thing is that it
seems like the iron spider suit was
influenced just
a little bit by the yellow jacket suit
not anything of significant importance
but interesting nonetheless
and in his last vlog when he's talking
to friday he says
let's mock up a prototype and dangle it
in front of the kid
just as a little incentive to keep on
the straight and narrow
should he ever want to join the avengers
so these are tony stark's direct
thoughts on peter parker
coming straight from his log and as you
can see he was extremely impressed with
him
right away from the beginning and it's
funny to see how much tony actually
wanted peter parker to join the avengers
for a pretty long time
when he was ready of course although
tony of course wanted him to become an
avenger at the end of spider-man
homecoming
but peter declined despite the really
awesome suit but as we can see from very
early on tony stark thought a lot about
peter parker and it definitely seemed
like to tony stark
peter parker was his protege someone who
he could train and mentor and possibly
go on to take on his mantle in the
future
but most importantly peter parker was
somebody that tony stark
deeply cared about which is why he made
things like the iron spider legs to
protect him
but let me know what you think about
this and be sure to subscribe because
i'll be going over
more details from the wakanda files mcu
time book
soon don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof